let me welcome everyone to today's
Thursday research conference we as as
those of you who are regulars in the
department know we we do this on an
intermittent basis over the summer we
don't have talks every week like we do
during the academic year but when
someone interesting is passing through
we make sure that everyone in the
department benefits from their knowledge
and wisdom and today is actually a
special kind of talk that we have in the
department some of you know we have been
starting up this new activity initiative
whatever you want to call it within the
department called the informatics
discovery lab the idea of being a an
effort to engage more with industry
disseminating our our work both our
research or education things that we
develop out into the real world and
working with companies and others to do
that and so today we have a visitor to
the department most the day x a couple
visitors from GE healthcare one of whom
is going to give a talk before I
introduce him though let me just ask
those of you who are here if you didn't
pick this up is a survey we're just
trying to get some feedback from people
who attend our conferences on what
things you might want to hear about and
other speakers we might invite and so
forth so then let me go ahead and
introduce our speaker Peter kin on front
who's a general manager in the
integrated care Group at GE who is based
in Seattle though like many people he
time other places around the country in
the world and he has actually quite a
resume which I won't cut into his talk
too much from going through but right
now he's a general manager in the
healthcare IT division of GE and he
leads a business called integrated care
that's focused on helping healthcare
providers rethink and rewire their care
delivery processes to excel under new
healthcare delivery models that are
taking shape in the united states such
as accountable care organizations and he
has a wealth of experience he's been
with GE for eight years he's worked for
other companies including consulting
company ernst & young and another health
IT vendor eclipsys which is now part of
allscripts he has an MBA from I won't
try to pronounce the French name of the
University i'll just use its acronym HEC
which is based in paris and he's done
work in many other places around the
world in europe and middle east so i
will turn it over to him than have him
enlighten us thank you
alright very good so i'm benjy for about
eight years my last roll is focused
around with my current role i should say
is focused on something we call
integrated care solutions and for GE
integrated care solutions is our
response to helping organizations with
what i think is an incredibly disruptive
time that's happening both in the US and
abroad right now I mean the payment
models I think are on are on the on the
cusp of being put on their head and I
think when you start to do that in a
healthcare system you're going to start
to see real change sorry real change and
and some some real challenges coming up
so i'm going to i want to talk to you
about what i'm seeing both in the US and
abroad around what organizations are
struggling with what problems they're
trying to solve i'm going to talk to you
a little bit about how we are responding
to it as a company and just try to talk
i mean if there's so much buzz and
discussion about what accountable care
organizations are in the market i just
want to at least kind of ground us on
what i think are some of the most
important things and foundations of that
and how it's playing out in the market
today what i would love is if you guys
would not be bashful interrupt me with
questions i personally much prefer that
than just kind of i've got i've got
slides i can jump around but i would
much prefer a discussion as we go i
think we got an hour and i would would
be thrilled to it to engage in your
questions so so don't be don't be shy
yeah one thing when people ask a
question if you could please hold down
the microphone in front of you so that
that gets recorded a little tape too
sure very good okay you can go to our
website to get a lot of the overview but
basically GE is a large healthcare
company part of a larger GE company we
do about 17 billion dollars operate in
many different countries got about a
billion dollars in R&D we have many
different businesses I represent really
two of them one is the healthcare IT
side and the other one is a group called
performance solutions which is our
healthcare consulting division and but
we have colleagues who work on medical
devices scanners
I think something like sixty to seventy
percent of all equipment you see in a
hospital we could potentially make or
sell to you so we're we're pretty big in
that in that space and to be frank they
they help pay our salaries it's a big
part of our of our of our company I
heard a great quote I was in DC there's
a customer of ours they're called a
called the MedStar and he said Peter you
know what health care is going to
transform at midnight we just don't know
what time it is now right and I think
it's such a critical thing for me I take
away I mean strategy is easy right
timing is hard strategies easy timings
hard I mean how many that the graveyard
is filled with patient engagement
companies who got it tried to get into
early right the these these innovators
are trying to get in health care has
been an industry it's been slow to
change but I believe we're starting to
see a point and the pressures are
starting to really come to fruition so I
like this quote and here's why I think
we're at a turning point the health
system is starting to change the way
they finance the way the way they
reimburse patients and you're seeing
this shift to more and more risk being
passed from what's essentially been in
the payers whether it's CMS or
commercial payers down into the provider
space and there's three market vectors I
want us to be thinking about first of
all it's the ACO it's the ACO growth
right everybody's probably read the
headlines you know with Obamacare you're
seeing more and more of these acos
popping up i think the latest count is
something like 400 i hear there's 700
applications pending for the next round
you know i go to the the brookings
dartmouth learning sessions and they
just held their conference in DC a
couple few weeks back three years ago
everybody was there saying this is a
load of load of crap i think i can say
that on the microphone and they were
fighting the rules it wasn't fair was
unimplemented the year after that they
were saying they'd made some changes and
they were starting to get in and share
learnings and then this year everybody
was talking about how they get the
wave so it's not just a CMS a CMAC of
the doing but they're now doing that
with that now they're doing it was Cigna
they're doing it with other commercial
providers which means they're building
they're going beyond dipping their toes
and they're building more capabilities
and I think it's interesting to watch
that however what I would pause it is
that the ACO growth is probably one of
but it's just one part of the transition
and I would look at things like Medicare
Advantage where you're seeing basically
the full capitated rates being pushed
down to providers in some of these
scenarios and look at Medicaid organs a
great state at look at how the state is
managing the Medicaid populations all of
this forces healthcare organizations to
think about when you're at risk for
these populations you can't deliver care
the same way you've been doing it for
the decades that's preceded us it's not
about volume it's going to be about
value okay so we do some very basic math
from a technology perspective we think
it's a multi-billion dollar opportunity
at and Citibank recently published
report they think it's about a 10 to 17
billion dollar opportunity we're a
commercial company we we want to return
value to our shareholders these these
kinds of things are important to us at
the end of the day this is this is this
is why you're seeing a lot of
competition and investment going into
this space I won't go through this a lot
but has anybody read the oliver rhyme
Wyman report that's out there around
this shift of value it's a good read if
it's it's it's available free on the on
the internet I think they've done a nice
job there they've got some partners
there who are pretty pretty well
educated there they are really talking
about the shift of volume and looking at
the different payment models and how how
the you know it's all about following
the lives following the covered lives
and they do a nice job of uncovering
some of them some of those trends but
you guys have seen graphs like that top
right I'm sure in your informatics
classes or other other things at the end
of day it's about it's a battle it's a
battle of scarce resources right health
systems need to focus their resources
where they want to improve quality and
reduce costs on the patients that will
that most need it or that will most
engage in it or most be or be most
activated by it we don't have resources
to spread it across the whole
populations right so that's why
analytics informatics etc have such an
important role to play in this okay okay
so i think my last page in the market
but i'm an economics guy and i think
it's so important to think about what
are the economics look like around let's
take let's take the the the ACO
contracts as an example so imagine a
medicare hco with a hundred thousand
lives let's take a rough ballpark of
average spend per patient of say twelve
twelve twelve fifty so you got about a
1.2 billion dollar worth a spend for a
hundred thousand lives okay these
organizations what they're saying with
these ACL contracts is we commit or
we're going to wear goal is to reduce
the cost of those hundred thousand
patients I'm going to reduce the rate of
growth around those hundred thousand
patients right while maintaining or
improving certain quality metrics all
right so by reducing that 1.2 billion
dollars you're essentially freeing up
between if you take a two percent
savings to us they have five percent
savings you're freeing up or you're
reducing about 25 million 263 million in
quote-unquote savings okay of which
they're going to share a percentage with
the payer a lot of these ACO contracts
with CMS are fifty-fifty share some of
them in the earlier days we're a little
bit different but just for simplicity
they basically get a payback of 12 to 30
million on the on the on the CMS lives
which correlates to about ten to twenty
six dollars per member per month so per
one of those hundred thousand
population and again I don't know what
you guys are if this is just this maybe
just real basics but the industry is
changing the way they start to talk
about these things right per member per
month was not something that hospitals
or health systems talked about much
that's a payer thing that was for the
payers right now in the discussions I
have day in day out with customers
they're all talking about how do what
you know what's the right pmpm spend how
many care managers do I higher / /
populations what kinds of Informatics do
I need do I need in order to identify
those high-risk populations etc etc so
essentially imagine you're imagining
your advocate in Chicago who's done a
nice job of publishing their learnings
in the space they took on a hundred
thousand or 150,000 CMS lives about
another 300,000 Blue Cross lives and
they they they claim they purport to get
about two percent savings across that so
what did they do with the money I know
what would you guys do if you were going
after a 1.2 billion dollar spend what
would you do any ideas
yep yeah so you put incentives in place
you get your physicians aligned and you
get some clear quality metrics what else
would you do hire some good students and
informatics maybe yeah how does the
insurance company share those savings
with the medical providers and i'm not
sure what sort of formulas or plans they
have to be able to do that because
you've got to incent the provider to
decrease the level of services yeah i
think that kind of plays on the earlier
point so let's imagine in this way it
was simple so advocate or these other
organizations they get fifty percent of
those savings kind of paid back at the
end of the year and a check it's then up
to these organizations to think about
how they share those incentives with
with the participating physicians and
other and other groups good point what
else what else any other ideas of what
what you would do to go after that a
little bit this morning but you know
you've got to keep turning the crank
right so you have to invest in the
system and the tools and the
technologies and the training and the
people in order to keep doing that right
because it's not a it's not a stable
target it's a moving target you're going
to be expected to continue those cost
savings for several years and increase
them so how do you do that you need to
invest in the way to do then that's
right addition to you know incentivizing
people by sharing the savings with them
those that are generating that's right
that's right and the better models like
advocate geisinger Group Health
Cooperative Intermountain they look at
the low-hanging fruit with the
self-insured groups and me with them in
a dynamic way to make sure that they
know what areas they want to kind of
control costs and then they have some
partnership arrangement do that
different technologies are employed but
at all it completely
volves the clinicians and the metrics
may be reducing surgical site infections
and may be any number of things but as
Aaron said each year it's dynamic so
they get more progressive in it yeah I
agree i'm going to going to come back to
that idea of dynamic i think it's i
think it's a really important point any
other comments and what what people
would would do we'd spend spend your
money on yeah just to follow what Aaron
said I think a lot of the efforts are
going into Peter warehousing yeah how do
we actually build the databases so we
can take into better analysis your care
gaps are and how we filled them yep yeah
we're seeing a tremendous increase in
spending in that in that space and some
really interesting startup technologies
I mean now that could you comment on
that new I think it's not that new but
the notion of data binding at the user
end for these facilities are using
because that's a concept where I'm
seeing more about but in your space I'm
sure you work with it daily do you mean
in terms of some of the the late binding
technologies that are coming through
with the exact yeah yeah I can't I'm not
that's technically i would get out of my
depth a little bit when i start to talk
about these things but what we're seeing
is a couple couple of things a couple
interesting firms one is we have a joint
venture with microsoft something we call
Kara dime where we're focused on some
technology in this space I also follow
groups like if you've seen the Explorers
group coming out of cleveland clinic or
healthcare catalyst i think is a really
interesting group coming out of Salt
Lake one thing that we're finding is
that the data warehouses of the past
have struggled in some ways in that they
they create these they go through
tremendous long cycles of designing the
perfect data model and what happens is
they kind of never get to the end state
of how do we get the value from that and
so we're seeing is more more flat data
structures where you bring the data in
in its raw form kind of with all the
impurities that exist and then what you
do is you add value enhance that with
with
through different parsing technologies
through different data sets that you
combine but you kind of let the
informatics teams play with that in its
raw fashion and then refine it as you go
so you might when you find out that
really important nugget of information
you might then move to a more
traditional cube or other kinds of
structures where you might worry but you
do that for performance but you keep
that raw data and its impurities because
there's a lot of value in that it
actually is when you I bet you guys see
that in some of your research with EHR I
mean sometimes if you clean up all that
data that that may be problems in the
way the EHR is capturing the data you
kind of never correct for it down the
road so so we're seeing a lot of that I
don't know if that answers your question
but yeah okay good so anyways so the
point is you the point is this this is
this is what people are going after the
economics of investment revolve around
this when you're talking about this
integrated care or more accountable care
space but look at the difference between
the dual eligibles the the Medicare
Medicaid kind of populations which are
kind of a proxy for quite high risk
populations and say a more commercial
population I mean just look at the
difference in terms of the the money
that can be freed up and it and then if
you start to think about well the
strategy i deploy for my i needed
something which is which is scalable for
my dual eligibles but as well as my
broader populations because as somebody
was saying earlier this is needs to be
dynamic this is a learning system right
what you may be focusing on your your
top high risk patients today in a couple
years time you'll be focusing on the
wellness and a much broader set of
populations and so these economics
become really really important right if
I may if I may a supplier into the
market and I'm pricing my solution and
if I'm going into a dual eligible I
might think of a certain pricing
structure but that that doesn't work
when you get out into a broader sets of
populations and so it's a real challenge
that these organizations are going
through okay
payers have been living in this world
for decades all right so let me just
share some of the research that we've
done internally at GE and it's to come
back and answer that question what do
you do about this change what are
organizations investing in in terms of
new capabilities first of all we funded
some of this some of our own focus
groups in and research of ourselves and
we also there's a ton of stuff out there
to to leverage as well and first of all
we started with it with a with
hypothesis that there's there's three
pillars to responding to the shift from
volume to value the first pillar is how
do I manage the financial risk that's
inherent in that new world okay what
systems what capabilities do I need the
second one is how do i coordinate the
care with population health or care
management systems that help me
coordinate care across the continuum and
thirdly how do I engage the patients in
this new paradigm to drive more
compliance around what is evidence-based
care but also more loyalty within the
system and what we what we said was it's
not just a simple install it and walk
away or build it and walk away these
things need to evolve and have this kind
of optimization curve to it so what you
might implement now needs to have an
optimization piece which comes back and
and informs how those systems evolve and
then we went out and we're as we started
to talk to the market we realized wow
there's tremendous diversity you know
you talked about Intermountain and and
guys in urine and those kinds of firms
what about the hospital I was born in
New Hampshire they've signed up to three
ACO contracts they got two small
hospitals an integrated physician
practice but they've never ever thought
about taking on risk other than basic
pay for performance and fee-for-service
so they've gone out and signed up about
40,000 lives put themselves at risk and
have no idea I don't want I don't want
to I mean
they have some idea that they don't
really know how they're going to move
the needle on that cost okay and there's
or if you look at the numbers of if you
look at the people that are getting the
press about sign up to these ACOs has
anybody asked themselves how the hell do
you do that with 12,000 lives here the
5,000 lives here I mean what we learn
about risk is that risk is good against
big sets of populations not these little
micro populations so as a comment and
commentator I struggle to see how that
plays out I think this is kind of place
to a consolidation game at some point
which which is I'm not quite sure what
the end state is but I can tell you the
end state is not the ACOs we read about
in the papers today today the end state
can't be whoo-hoo I got 10,000 patients
on an eight on a co contract and I hope
to get two percent savings that's not
that can't be the end state right so
this has got to be a step toward
something else and that's why what we
see is organizations dipping their toes
to be frank the ACO contracts they sign
up today often there's no downside risk
for two years so what are they we know
it's okay that they're contracting
capabilities outpace their care delivery
capabilities but at some point they will
move into more mainstream or get try to
get two 4runners or I think or I think
something else will happen that they'll
they'll break out of this move this mode
okay anybody see it differently than
that I'm kind of my own commentary but
challenge me if you think I'm I'm off
track not a challenge but so you're
saying the simple economics of it will
will entice people to it rather than
forcing them to it is that what you're
saying I think that's what they're
trying to do I think they they're
they're scared to death of the 90s when
managed care broke the backs of the
system and the they're scared to death
of putting too much I mean simply put
you know the pioneering acos kind of the
names that some of we've thrown around I
think there's 18 or 20 of these these
organizations
you know they either never left the HMO
days or they had a health plan or
they're very sophisticated kind of
organization right I think all of them
might have our I had a had a health plan
I'm correct um where where do you see
you know I'm thinking you know the
emails I get from our organization you
know our 14,000 employee organization
that sexy self insured yeah where do you
see the role of self-insured
organizations and I don't know the
details of you know whether there's some
like insurance that ohsu has if it
exceeds a certain level or something
like that but where did those fit and I
know a lot of large corporations now our
self insured I think they play a real
big role actually I we see often with
systems of size of equivalent size their
first step is often they their first
step is not an ACO the first step is
their own employee base and that's what
they start to build build the muscle for
some of these things so we see that
quite a bit actually but again I don't
think I don't think that's an end-state
it's it's a it's a learning process by
the way and I think these examples are
just ways of enticing people into the
system because i think the CMS i mean
they're they're scared to death that
everybody's gonna this is going to break
the system right I mean they want this
to be successful in my opinion isn't the
answer just merely at some point like
they did another reimbursement system
CMS to just say that if you're not in
some may co then your payments or less
oh for sure totally that is that's that
is happening now yeah
yeah yeah but I think at the in the in
the world we're in now there's still a
little bit of that enticing right it's
that it's that carrot and stick kind of
thing do you know why Oregon is so far
behind the curve and all this because I
understand there's only one pioneer ACO
on the entire state and it's somewhere
out in the West is there any food you
have any reason does well yeah I would
say you guys are kind of advanced but
our acos Medicare ACOs our Medicaid but
I don't understand the commercial payers
are picking up on as well well right so
I'm sure that advocate considers
themselves an ACL irrespective of
whether or not they've contracted with
Medicare what I'm saying that I thought
the CCOs at least the waiver was a
Medicaid convention right and a cos were
a Medicare convention but that's right
then why would the CCOs have anything to
do with Medicare in other words why
would I would argue the capability it's
the same the population is different and
that the way it gets reimbursed just
might be I don't know the CCO details
that well but I would imagine it's a
similar kind of construct the commercial
payers are taking the ACO are taking
that what you see in CMS a CO and they
are applying some of the same terms with
their own tweaks and local negotiations
so you're a CEO is becoming more of a
generic term it's not just a CMS term
anymore
boyer based coverage you're going to see
the ACOs get into that business I mean
that's how they're going to sustain as
you can't I mean I program manager nay
co in Texas and you can't live on being
a Medicare easy oh yeah hi grace you
know you're pre-empting your pre-empting
my slide I couldn't agree more than
sorry but those you'll see them starting
to take on risk through employers and
managing the health of employees in the
same way that they're trying to manage
health a great and Medicare Advantage
and Medicaid and other thing you'll see
other products and things coming out to
be gap covered yeah depending on where
you are and where those acrs fall into a
ce o--'s rather fall into health care or
the health insurance exchanges what's
allowed I mean we're doing that in Texas
right now Texas a little weird but we're
going to be able to offer primary care
coverage through our ACO an indemnity
plan for catastrophic and then we
haven't asked where you come from I live
here in order okay but we have an ACO we
actually applied for a pioneer and
didn't get it I think we got in the
second cut it was positions a CEO okay
we also have another one Southwest you
space okay so what do you think of this
physician-led ACO there's a tremendous
amount so oh I'm sorry okay I'll try to
get closer i came in late so I'm sorry
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
happening in the market with its a
tremendous amount of physician let ACOs
in quantity being published around a
around ACOs so no hospitals and it's an
interesting it's an interesting play
well but I mean they have no hospital in
there in there I yeah we're we're an
indie right we're in and it's harder for
independence than it is for Hospital
things they steal stuff at them because
they've got the bullpen they've already
you know like OHS your instance has epic
right and they yeah
we connect to other partners and you
know so there's their value in that but
there's also value in the private ETO as
well where you talk about smaller
populations yeah those smaller
populations don't necessarily fit in
well to a population health model you
might get more traction you know them
dealing with a smaller population or
special communities see a lot of that as
well a lot of a COS around Chinese
health care communities Bay Area okay
actually I think also in some ways those
physician practices have the the
nimbleness and is that they don't have
they don't have to keep the beds full so
in some ways they can we see quite a bit
of innovation happening in that space
because they can move quickly whereas
some of these larger systems again in
these big kind of conference rooms and
they have committees to make decisions
and at one end of the table you've got
the hospital CEO is saying how do i I
mean reducing it emits is great but i'm
still getting you know okay I budge over
it I gotta pay so hospitals struggling
because the readmit rates have gone down
because the quality Seng exactly exactly
I was talking something today says I
don't want to be best-in-class Don Reed
mitts I want to be just in the middle
where it kind of makes sense so how can
your analytic help me stay just in the
middle and like you said it's a dynamic
system so yeah that that incentive might
change in volume months right all right
interesting thank you okay so we we came
we understood why trying to pick out
what are the really what do people
really focusing on from an unmet need
what are they what are they one of the
real problems and we landed on three
themes so this is and I was asking a
question what would you guys do what
would you spend your money on if you
were looking to move from volume to
value this is what we found from our
market research that the market was
spending money on and sorry for my
coarse language they're not just
spending money on it they're rethinking
their processes it's it's more more than
just that but the first thing is they
want to understand essentially the risk
that they're signing up for right so
we're calling that we're coining that
population and contract analytics
is we think it's about the populations
but it's also how does it impact the
contract that they have with the payer
whether it's CMS or another pair and in
that bucket you've also got how do I
help predict what the value of a certain
intervention could be or how do I help
predict what the right cohort of
population will will react to certain
care care intervention programs etc so
you've got a this is a from a foreign it
for an informatics class I mean this is
just this is ripe with decade's worth of
research and and and work i mean it's we
see the big guys going after this
weather if you're optum or whether
you're verisk or some of the or Aetna's
group or are others you know these guys
are coming at it they're saying hey
we've got hundreds of actuarial
informatics people on staff we know this
stuff right then you've got the small
firms in San Francisco who are the data
guys who just know how to crack data and
then you've got this kind of mix of
people maybe come out of the disease
management space and trying to prove
bring kind of predictive analytics to it
I think it's an incredibly exciting
exciting time and then you've got a nice
not to overlook you've got some
fantastic faculties that at different
organizations like this one and others
who are doing tremendous amount of work
in this space and so I think it's just
ripe with with innovation the bet that
we're making from GE is that first of
all I still go to see how the payer
based solutions get real traction would
you guys want to be negotiating the data
from that the same person you negotiate
with I don't get that all right great
great products I mean I I value I think
they're they have a tremendous amount of
capability but I don't understand how
that plays out in the long run all right
we're provider based company we don't
sell if we don't sell any products to
payers so I we kind of I live in that
world and that's that's our that's our
client base but they're scared of that
they don't see they see that as
that information asymmetry as being very
threatening to them so so we where we
think we have this is an area what we're
investing in we have we have data that
we can leverage which is claims data but
also clinical data I mean man we've been
putting in all these EHR systems if we
try and big base all of our all of our
predictive analytics around claims data
what the hell do we put all that EHR
stuff in form right so so we're focused
on that we think there's a there's a
good opportunity of this the PO would be
the rules for everybody but I can tell
you this is definitely one area where
organizations are spending money the
second thing and it goes back to your
pointer net in that green area is around
how do you manage the financial risk and
that's everything from eligibility and
benefits referrals network optimization
payment adjudication all those things
that payers have been doing now suddenly
become a provider role and that's more
complicated or at least it's different
than just coding and billing coding and
billing so basically that's the one at
one of the products we offer the ability
to subscribe to your care monthly basis
uh-huh so it's like concierge but it's
not with all the bells and whistles okay
what is it when you say subscribe to you
care what do you what do you mean by
that well in that in this particular
model it's a membership organization
nonprofit providers and the patient's
join and the nonprofit axis to fight by
juicy fiduciary intermediary handling
the transaction but the relationship is
putting the patient of dr.
and they're paying 40 bucks a month
after primary care cover okay should one
once a month or as many visits azhar
allowed under whatever contract you have
but those types of things as well and
then allowing those those types of
models to be accepted is qualified
health care coverage Care Act two is
another okay and then the third area we
think is a really big area around we're
going to click calling that care
management and patient engagement I
should stop and say our research said
don't think about these things think
about these things in the connected like
don't think about them in silos in some
ways health has been to siloed for too
long so they said patient engagement is
more effective if you think about it as
part of your broader care management or
population health capability as opposed
to being something kind of off in a
corner and kind of a science project any
comments and you think i'm missing
anything here no okay i think i just got
a couple more pages than i'd love to get
some more discussion so the other thing
is we think about is at the end of the
day we're doing this to solve solve for
a problem and kind of mike my consulting
background i like to think of things in
terms of you know what are we trying to
drive for an outcome what are the levers
that we're going to try and pull on to
get there and if you think about the
outcomes on the right you know again
metrics that payers have been thinking
about it for a while will become more
and more what providers are talking
about so you know understanding what
your populations hospital days per
thousand ed admits readmissions
compliance to care on a number of
factors you know essentially you know
like if you guys probably follow Brent
James down at Intermountain and some of
his work you know I love the work that
he's done around how to reduce
unwarranted variation and and and some
of that space and I think this
gives it a real home right I think
sometimes where where where dr. James
theories struggled to get into reality
is that there it wasn't always
financially incentive to reduce clinical
variation and I think this gives dr.
James a fantastic home for his theories
and his methodologies that he that he
purports so that's the first piece and
this is where a lot of the low-hanging
fruit is where people are going after
you know simple thing keep people out of
the ED right that's where you know these
early things is is you can get to two to
five percent fairly easily in these
early years by doing some simple things
that won't work however in year three or
four or five and do that with a quality
mindset and quality metrics you know I
think often get the question and you
guys probably study this a little bit
too is what's tims between now and the
HMO days and I think there's a couple
differences first of all I think we're
putting quality much more at the
forefront of this than we did back in
the 90s and secondly I think we have
better data to measure it I hope we do
at least right and I think this will
this will be a key piece to the puzzle
and the third element is will become
more and more of an issue it's how do I
do that in a cost-effective way so how
do i set up an organization that is
efficient and provides a return on
investment we have to be frank right I
can go in high or 100 care managers to
go after that population of 10,000 but
can I do the same with a with 10 care
managers right those are the kinds of
things and how do I build an operating
system yeah just agree yeah I don't see
any any other way around it right yeah
you know one question is where does the
physician fit in here in terms of
guideline-based care you know somebody
comes in and they want a whole-body MRI
you know there's no incentive right now
for the physicians as a Oh
a you know will order the whole body MRI
where does that come in the guiding the
physician as to what's appropriate
what's not appropriate but for me it's
it's kind of part and parcel of some of
the levers that you drive in those first
two ones when you do that you drive that
physician alignment around evidence for
to reduce unnecessary variation but also
to improve quality I mean the three the
physician is at the heart of all of this
stuff really is yep well I think this
speaks the importance of process yeah
like the people who have been able to
effectively implement guideline care
work from a bottom-up rather than a
top-down basis like we do the 90s yeah
if you tell positions that you can't do
a whole body scan lets you got the
syndication it's amazing number of that
indication that pop up hmm if instead
they feel like they've been represented
in the process sure then there's some
work that says they'll buy into it and
actually go with the flow right
especially they're being centerport yeah
I agree dr. James would agree right I
think that's that's a lot of his
philosophy I think the I was saying
earlier in our meeting that I this is
not a this this is not a technology
solve it's a much more we think actually
the service and and the kind of
organizational change that goes along
with this is far bigger than the
technology alone really really truly far
bigger which I think place place at that
point okay any other questions
that's it
so we have 15 minutes left I love to
hear I love to hear how how you guys see
kind of this shift and how it's
impacting kind of things that you're
studying things that you're thinking
about in your careers if you think I'm
crazy if you think this is just a phase
is going to go away you can tell me you
know i I've thought about this i'm sure
many in this room have you know i think
it's important i mean clearly we you
know we spend a lot more money on health
care in the united states and we don't
get as good a benefit the only thing
that worries me is if we get completely
fixated on costs you know there are some
I mean clearly we do too much in health
care there's there's so much evidence
that a lot of the tests we order the
treatments we prescribe you know have
sometimes are not are not only not
beneficial but also detrimental but
there are though some things that work
and you know there's some things that
are beneficial and my one hope in that
in in this move to sort of bring these
very real cost problems under control is
that we don't kind of lose sight of what
health care is really trying to do which
is if not make people healthy at least
going to bring them back from the
precipice of being sick yeah yeah do you
think in in your view do you think
that's a real risk that do you think
what you think we've gotten the equation
wrong or a real real risk for getting it
wrong or um in some instances you know
you know on the other hand I'm actually
tremendous skeptic of a lot of what we
do in medicine and you know I've medical
training you know I one of my biggest
you know frustrations when I was doing
some amount of clinical practice was how
undated driven it was people were
deciding to do things based on hunch and
especially when that hunch was
financially rewarding to them so it
would be nice to dissociate the sort of
financial reward from from people
acting on hunches I I think we need to
do a lot better job in using data to see
you know what really does and doesn't
work in healthcare you know but but
again just at the end of the day I hope
it's not completely dollar driven yeah I
from a personal perspective I hope so
too yeah well some of them to take care
of that situation some of the models we
created 10 or 15 years ago we looked at
because of the fraud and abuse laws if a
certain percentage of patients would
typically get some kind of intervention
we might have a caller around it so if
people try to go Bo below that then that
could create a fraud and abuse I agree
with dr. Hurst there doesn't seem to be
anything built in these there's an
exception for fraud and abuse for
certain aspects of these ACOs so I think
that is a risk and then on the other
side be interested in your answer this
question that I haven't been able to
answer one pediatrician from Atlanta
once it in am a conference that up and
said well accountable for what she said
I have patients who eat three big macs a
day how can I possibly i can tell them
not to eat big macs if i ever saw their
parents i could tell them but that's
another concern that some of the
clinicians i think right for the hay so
having these models and i think that's
that's the that's the counter argument
that i think is the scariest I mean
Clayton Christensen if you guys follow
that of a Harvard have you saw his
article in The Wall Street Journal or he
was basically saying this is this is all
wrong this isn't going to work in the
end of the day and it was basically
because it comes down to his basic thing
was it comes down to the patient's
behavior and you know we're not we're
not really doing enough to change those
behaviors and I think there's a lot of
validity and that I I do however think
that's why we that's why we put it front
and center and some of those some of the
needs and what that organizations will
need to evolve over time I don't know I
don't know I mean I was with a doctor a
little while ago he says my patients
have a right to kill themselves yeah I
think so yeah I think I'm hopeful
because while anything can be taken to
abuse
I think that having a more data and
analytic driven approach allows us to
change it to a focus on value and maybe
that value needs to be stratified and
and and and grouped according to
particular patients in particular you
know situations if somebody's going to
you know eat three big macs a day and
you can't convince them otherwise then
you know that becomes a certain patient
cohort and some groups may be better at
dealing with that patient cohort and
other and there for creating more value
for the money for for the healthcare
dollars for those particular people now
obviously it's never going to be as good
as if they would stop eating those big
macs but it still allows us to ask those
questions and and focus on the value
that that can be created also you know
it may this is this this is also you
know prime for the you know the sort of
slippery slope but if people are going
to you know smoke or eat too many big
macs you know their personal
responsibility in their health care
costs might have to be higher if you
insist on behaving in certain ways you
know the society isn't going to
subsidize your risk is as much as
somebody who doesn't do this I just did
you guys read the articles and Health
Affairs around patient engagement and I
mean it's a local group called insignia
they do they do the Pam scores I think
you know I think there's some
interesting work happening in that space
I that was like it yeah I think your
remarks who are excellent right on but
one thing that you could maybe do for
the part of the group is relate this to
what might be employment opportunities
for certificate and masters students so
I mean I think that that's on the minds
of many people those of us that are
hoping to teach it's sort of less on
their mind but huh the vast majority of
us are you know or would be looking for
a job and it seems like there's a lot of
opportunities and could you give people
an idea of where that you might see them
yeah yeah good question so a couple
things one is so if we kind of go back
to the
GE businesses that are focusing on on
this on this issue we're taking we have
three tracks to the kind of solutions
we're developing one is software
development so we're we're looking at
things like care management population
health systems second one is around
analytics so we are you know we we hire
we have teams of clinical informatics
ists that work with with essentially
technology development people and
customers try and find you know what are
those high-value questions that we're
trying to solve for our customers and
how do we ensure that we you know answer
them in the right way and that we can
actually productize that too to make to
make money and then a third element of
our team which is not really thought of
much a GE but is our consulting team i
have i have three doctors in my staff I
have several many even more nurses in my
staff I have a lot of people have spent
time as data analyst either in health
systems or in in other vendors and
essentially what we are what we're
looking to do is we're trying to provide
a value proposition to healthcare
organizations that say we're going to
help you along this journey from volume
to value and we're going to help you
kind of talk about some of those
outcomes I showed on that page and we're
going to bring some right domain
expertise to the table we're going to
bring some right technology the table
and oh by the way we know you're going
to have stuff already that we want to
leverage like your epic EMR system or
your data warehouse that you spent ten
years developing and so you know we're
really looking at people who are I call
it multilingual people who are can work
across multiple systems it's amazing
don't know how many i don't know how
many IT systems ohs you have it but i'm
sure it's in the hundreds right and
that's the environment which a solutions
provider needs to operate so you know
just to summarize clinical informatics
people who may have a clinical
background themselves with it's an MD RN
we like people who are problem solvers
it's kind of something we begin we're
really looking to interview for so we're
p
can solve problems with a customer and
we want to be able to recognize value in
the way we price our solutions to our
customers for that so can do that in
either a product development kind of
mindset or in a solution delivery kind
of mindset hopefully that answers
questions great great question okay five
minutes left listen if there were fewer
hands in the back i'm not sure i didn't
get to but yeah so we've talked a lot
about the shift in the industry and we
touched a little bit about shifts in
culture have you seen much researcher
aware of much there there are cultural
shifts that happen with things you know
like seat belts for instance you know it
was a time of nobody you seat belts and
now you know lots of things happen laws
change rates change for injured things
like that are you seeing any threads of
change in the culture that you find
encouraging around some of those bigger
topics we were discussing around patient
engagement and those kind things to be
frank i'm disappointed on how little ice
i see there we in the market research
that we did around around really
changing patient behaviors and we
touched a couple hundred organizations
it was it was actually more saddening
than it was optimistic we to be frank we
had people come to us in focus groups
and interviews and proclaiming to be
patient engagement leaders and when we
asked them for evidence of what that
meant they showed us a webpage where
patients could schedule or view a lab
result or the firm you know they may
have gotten an appointment reminders
kind of thing out to people so without
being may be too negative in that space
I feel like that's an area of tremendous
tremendous is it's right for a lot more
a lot more effort not to say there are
pockets of good things that people are
doing you know that that MedStar person
I quoted in the beginning or looking at
ways that we
they have a group of six hundred
high-risk elderly population that are
trying to manage in a virtual care model
and really try and get out to their
homes and connect it with device data
and find just fine totally different
care models on how to engage those
patients I mean that that stuff is
fantastic but it feels kind of subscale
right now those projects and so I don't
quite understand how they become they
start to touch the masses that's where
I'm that's right kind of get get worried
about it yep where do you think things
like meaningful use fit fit into this
picture you know there is some pushback
from Congress around continuing to fund
meaningful use I I small my personal
commentary rather than a real informed
commentary it's not my area of expertise
I see it as more like they've they've
done a good job of kind of getting the
table stakes set i mean i think the EHR
adoption is a an incredibly important
enabler for the system and i want to i
want to make sure we continue to push
that needle you know when i read like
the rand study and other things about
the ROI and some of these EHR systems
it's it's a bit scary but I don't know I
kind of feel like we didn't ask the
airline industry with the ROI was on
kind of automating some of their systems
maybe they do themselves but I just
think there's those basic things that we
just have to say as an industry we want
and will pay for it and you know let's
optimize it let's be smart about how we
incentivize it but you know from a from
a again I take my GE hat off even though
this is being recorded having traveled
the world and works in multiple
countries I'm amazed at how much
healthcare IT spend in u.s. is compared
to a broad I can't understand whether
it's our firm or other firms how we can
spend why we talk about hundreds of
millions of spend around seiya an EHR
system here when
it's fairly similar capability and
technologies being sold for one-tenth
the price in other countries so this
something's happened around the
incentives and other things where I feel
like that we've got that wrong so that's
off the record though agree to attach
while to take vessels that come in the
door and tax billing codes to them yeah
that's that's more or less what they're
built for they're not necessarily built
to improve care through quality and
that's why we're in this transition I
mean so it's like you said it's kind of
hard to kind of hard to measure the ROI
yet because we're still in the spending
stage right we haven't been trip to get
to ROI and the system is still in
transition true but man if they built
their their business cases on a better
precision and accuracy of coding to
optimize billing and those things I mean
that they shift that we're underway if
this come if this takes root like it
will well we'll come back and bite them
I think flash it's kind of been brewing
since februari all these people have
each ours now we're saying you know this
is crap software or this isn't doing
what I need or it doesn't do everything
I need and they're looking for ways to
change and get rid of what they got
already after a year yeah yeah so maybe
as an economist you can appreciate it
maybe you agree or disagree but you know
I think part of the problem you know in
general I'm a supporter of free market
solutions i actually think markets work
great for the airlines you know with in
fact the airlines get into trouble when
they move away from that but having you
know Delta competing with United the the
problem in health care is that the
market in my view really isn't free in
so many ways you know when we get sick
we don't go shopping you know just a
couple weeks ago I was driving down to
corvallis my daughter graduating college
and there's a billboard
advertising 485 dollar MRIs and clearly
aimed at people who you know have no
health insurance but then I was thinking
you know i'm fortunate enough i work at
ohsu i have health insurance if i needed
an MRI would i choose that one because i
knew it was cheaper and and of course
not first of all not only do i have
insurance but also i'd also be wandering
in the back of my mind you know what's
the quality of this but but you know
free markets work when people have
access to information and and in health
care we not only don't have that but
often just can't have it because we can
only know so much and i think part of
our problem in the u.s. is we try to
impose a free market solution on health
care when it's questionable whether it's
it's really going to work i mean i think
markets can do some things in some areas
may be around health IT but you know the
fundamental decision to spend money on
medic on medicine is you know it's
difficult to drive that purely as a
financial transaction as an economist
maybe you agree or disagree with that I
didn't do it I tend to agree I mean I
especially having lived lived abroad
nine years in Europe 36 in France two in
the UK so I have personal experiences
that that kind of back that up but
doesn't my personal views so I know
we'll see how it plays out in the u.s. I
think it's we got a long road ahead of
us and one thing I one thing i do did i
do love some of the innovation that's
happening in America and I think we do
have a system which kind of helps some
of that that innovation really take root
not so much on the cheap MRIs but I mean
I was with a colleague deal a day and
and he had whole family had strep throat
and he basically went to CVS and you
know these kind of minute clinics or
whatever whatever they're called and he
was quite happy with it with the care
was instant he walked in etcetera and I
think if anything that kind of change at
least disrupts the system right and I
think the u.s. is where think we're good
at that right so
some fairly powerful lobbies the united
states that are very upset about the doc
in the box practices oh for sure
definitely it's not easy so but we're
straying beyond my my expertise so I
think we've come up time yeah I really
thank everybody just this OneNote you
have my my name I think in the invite
etc i'm on linkedin if you want to reach
out to me don't hesitate it's a small
world in health care especially when you
go healthcare informatics and other
things so and i'm only up the street to
seattle so thank you